talk about this relationship Diego
between the United States and Mexico it
is it that border goes both ways right
now and if you shut it down it'll shut
down both ways
that's expectations any unilateral
measure can create that type of effect
Mexico is the third largest trading
partner half a trillion dollars so
people are talking about the 60 billion
but they are forgetting the fact that
the u.s. there are six million jobs u.s.
jobs exporting things to Mexico yeah
there's a million news outlets
economists and researchers had just
spent the last 12 hours working out what
a 20 percent tariff actually meant I
wonder as an investor when they just
ignored all of that nonsense and just
went out and bought a load of pesos
yesterday when we got another sell-off
yes they did but we think that the base
is cheap and obviously given the
devaluation of Mexico that is the
maximum facility has been conspicuous
within emerging markets
you were argue that any regular tariff
would be more than absorbed already by
current prices meaning that meaning that
Mexico should be fine you know what the
market seems to be predicting seems to
be I don't know what kind of worst case
may be that not only the tariff is
imposed but then you have the worst
possible outcome out of the election in
Mexico next year so else is that what
the currency market is telling you to or
is it that you need to see reality in
actual steps for the peso to take
another leg lower so what we're looking
for at the moment is we've got a fair
value range of twenty one to twenty one
sixty given everything we've seen so far
and it's not just the Mexican pesos
story we've also got a reasonably
constructive view on the US dollar but
we do see potential to break to new
highs and dollar Mex just purely on the
fact that there still is a lot of
headline risk and you could see a much
more aggressive tone from both sides of
the border and you know like you said at
the start of the segment this is a very
important trade relation to both sides
border but it's not clear that the
administration acknowledges that at the
moment well so many things are not clear
right now Diego and one of them is
exactly how much is real as we've been
talking about is this actually in some
ways working to president Trump's
advantage in this sense if the markets
are not overreacting
he hasn't to worry as much about that he
can continue with his negotiation sort
of stance he's throwing a lot of things
out
the way you might in a negotiation
rather than in really acting as
president estates yeah but I think in
international relationships these
negotiations are slightly different
because it's not that you have only one
set of things to negotiate you know why
would you use single out Mexico at the
end of the day you have five F four
hundred billion dollars of trade similar
trade situation with Canada and China
you have bigger trade deficits with
Japan and Germany so why Mexico just
because you want to pay for the wall he
doesn't add up so the question is I
think that at the end of the day it
makes sense from a politics standpoint
that there it might make sense the
rhetoric but at some point time you have
to have a coherent international trade
policy yeah I'm trying to understand how
you can be an investor in this
environment be successful and one of the
examples was the election that if you
ignored the personality and the sound
bytes and focused on what was actually
going to be policy you made money and
this time around if you ignore the sound
bites in the theatre of spice to coming
out with a random line and just put that
to one side you can take opportunity of
some of these events and you did you
bought pesos yesterday and now the pesos
stronger on the day I just want to
understand from you if we get more of
these dislocations in the market and
you're looking at Mexico what assets are
you looking at beyond the currency
itself well in general in this case we
think that local bonds in pesos might be
the best near-term opportunity because I
think that that is the sector that has
been affected the most and one of the
things that we have noticed is that
despite the bad headlines the peso has
not weakened further so it feels that
the positions are already very bearish
so it's not that you cannot get worse
but we think that most of the bad
outcome has been already priced in